comment produire toutes sortes de fruits
et légumes à l'intérieur en milieu hyper
contrôlés 12 mois par année voyez des
serres où la haute technologie est au
service de l'autonomie alimentaire
on fait de la technologie pour produire
des denrées
qu'on soit dans le désert on souhaite
moins 60 degrés Celsius on peut parler
de carte à 6 fois plus de rendement
facilement juste avec une roue comme ça
sur un étage
les cerfs Audrey produisent sur près de
6000 mètres carrés en culture série
colle
mon père a fait ça en 1982 à offrir ça
fait 40 ans puis si tout le temps ce
qu'on a fait de la production maraîchère
donc moi c'est dans mon ADN
avec la grandement en cours André
Saint-Denis prévoit doubler sa
production en plus d'allonger sa saison
de culture en serre mais si les affaires
vont bien ici depuis deux ans le
producteur tente d'optimiser ses
rendements en économisant sur le
chauffage par exemple ici on peut voir
le beau gros calibre de laitue qu'on a
qu'on a pas dû grâce à la chaleur qu'on
a récupéré des fraises ça nous permet de
sauver 80% sur le chauffage une des plus
grosses dépenses qu'on a ensemble c'est
l'énergie pour le chauffage
et pour produire en serre dans un climat
comme celui du Québec l'énergie
séminaire de la guerre
[Musique]
notamment nos concombres à côté on va
voir vraiment tout ce qu'on peut aller
récupérer la chaleur des fraises donc
tout de suite là ça aide la rentabiliser
notre investissement
[Musique]
peut récupérer la chaleur produite par
les fraises c'est grâce à ce bâtiment
ériger à l'intérieur de la serre
derrière ces murs une véritable usine à
végétaux
dans cet environnement hyper contrôlé on
recrée les conditions optimales de
croissance des cultures aménagées à la
verticale
plutôt que d'avoir le soleil en haut et
donc d'avoir nécessairement les plantes
qui visent vers le haut essentiellement
le soleil est sur le côté et les plantes
vivent vers le soleil mais on est
capable donc de mettre plusieurs étages
ici on a 14 étages le haut
c'est ce producteur et ingénieur de
formation qui a développé cette
technologie j'ai vu mon père en arracher
ma mère en arraché c'est pour ça que
quand je regarde quel comment la
technologie va servir la grenomie je
comprends comment la technologie doit
être orchestrée pour que toujours le
système réponde à l'état de croissance
de la plante
on fait durer le lever stimuler du
soleil comme on veut en fonction de
l'évolution des plats ici même la brise
estivale est reproduite et c'est
important le vent ce qu'on a fait en
arrière des plans ici à des ballons de
ventilation qui poussent derrière le
plan à une température contre le système
un niveau d'humidité contrôlé le CO2
contrôlé les bourdons ont aussi été
intégrés à cette écosystème artificiel
en partie la pollinisation se fait vers
le vent mais elle se fait par les
insectes qui vont toucher la partie
femelle de la fraise au moment où la
fleur rouge
en un an ces murailles végétales peuvent
produire 90 000 kg de fraises pour vous
donner une idée la salle a fait ici là a
fait un peu moins de 600 mètres carrés
on produit l'équivalent ici de 1 hectare
un hectare c'est 10000 mètres carrés
pour assurer la viabilité de son système
de culture qui l'appelle sa ferme divers
Yves Dahou mise sur le partenariat avec
des maraîchers locaux comme André
Saint-Denis
propriétaire de son système cet
ingénieur de formation l'implante à même
des serres conventionnels déjà
existantes pour produire des fraises
les deux partenaires se partagent les
revenus générés par la vente des fraises
et le producteur en serre profite des
bénéfices énergétiques réalisés par
cette installation
[Musique]
on leur dit ben installons une ferme
d'hiver à côté de la production en serre
qui devient la fournaise de la serre en
même temps essentiellement tous
l'énergie de la lumière des fraises elle
est récupérée et envoyer dans une
thermopompe pour envoyer cette chaleur
là pour chauffer la serre on va vouloir
aider la rentabilité pas juste des
fraises mais aussi des tomates des
concombres des poivrons et tout ce qui
se passe à côté ça nous a permis de
cultiver de la salade à l'année ce qu'on
faisait pas avant donc lui est content
moi je suis content c'est gagnant
gagnant on va évaluer la capacité
d'énergie qu'on pourra récupérer des
fraises pour les autres sœurs parce que
c'est nouveau pour cette première
expérience de partenariat Yves Dahoo
avait déjà en poche un contrat de
distribution avec une grande chaîne
d'alimentation
nous on s'arrange pour que la
technologie livre la marchandise et on
va partager avec le maraîcher les
profits issus de la vente des fraises
pour payer la portion des technologies
et parlant technologies voici l'un des
derniers en matière de culture
maraîchère en milieu contrôlés
[Musique]
rotatives qui peuvent s'empiler pour une
production à grande échelle sont
actuellement sous l'observation des
scientifiques dans les serres
laboratoires de l'Université Laval si on
a quand même 1200 plans puisqu'on a 10
plans par plateau ce qui vient vraiment
identifier la production et l'espace
qu'on utilise une surface comme celle-ci
de culture c'est environ 18 mètres
carrés et ça occupe à peu près une
surface de 8 mètres carrés donc déjà en
serre on vient de doubler notre surface
de culture donc notre productivité
Martine Doret dirige depuis 2020 une
chaire de recherche qui teste et
développe des systèmes de culture en
environnement contrôlé
son objectif aider les producteurs
maraîchers à améliorer leur rendement
système rotatif que ce soit un système
vertical le secret dans l'automatisation
et le second avantage c'est vraiment de
pouvoir avoir une culture qui est
uniforme donc on voit ici que le on a un
éclairage artificiel qui nous permet
vraiment d'uniformiser la qualité de la
récolte et alors des problèmes de main
devraient agricoles l'automatisation
devient un atout précieux
les systèmes comme ça ça nous permet
d'automatiser donc de faire en sorte
qu'on peut diminuer de moitié au moins
là le nombre de travailleurs par unité
de surface ça nous permet aussi d'avoir
des sucs de production beaucoup plus
rapide donc on sort notre lait de ça à
peu près en 21 jours maximum 21 28 jours
donc on peut faire ça pour toutes les
types de production
mais s'il se démarque de la production
conventionnelle en serre ces systèmes de
culture intérieur ont un prix c'est dix
fois plus élevé que un coup de
construction de cerf des sables on est
rendu à peu près à 500 600 dollars du
mètre carré lorsqu'on parle des systèmes
vertical à l'intérieur on va facilement
multiplier par 10 c'est au niveau de la
productivité c'est quand même compétitif
pour les chercheurs comme pour leur
partenaire de l'industrie ce modèle de
production maraîchère ne sera viable que
si les développer en partenariat ou par
la mise en commun des
le système l'avenir c'est vraiment dans
l'intégration de plusieurs systèmes donc
à ce moment-là le surplus énergétique
que j'ai ici je vais l'utiliser pour
aller chauffer une serre donc le bilan
des deux va être va s'équilibrer en fait
tout le concept même il est en
partenariat avec les maraîchers mais
aussi dans l'écosystème économique
agricoles il faut que les prêts
agricoles les véhicules de financement
les programmes du MAPAQ s'appliquent
dans la production verticale et non pas
juste dans la production traditionnelle
les règles d'attribution de la
certification biologique devront aussi
être mieux adaptés à ces nouvelles
réalités technologiques
ces cultures verticales par exemple ne
peuvent obtenir la mention bio il y a
différentes conditions requises pour la
production bio dont l'accès au soleil
l'autre élément c'est qu'on est
considéré comme des arbres à fruits et
donc il y a un volume de terreau requis
minimum qui est représenté à l'extérieur
mais pas à l'intérieur
nous permettent de garder le CO2 à
l'intérieur nous permet d'aller
rechercher l'énergie qu'on retrouve dans
la vapeur d'eau donc dans la chaleur
latente on peut produire avec un zéro
empreinte carbone j'en suis convaincu
[Musique]